Lucia: 就是做可行性研究报告
Lucia: Is to make feasibility study reports.
Lucia: 其中包括您的预算
Lucia: Including your budget.
Alice: 我们的预算是不是告急了
Alice: Is our budget running low?
Lucia: 是不是告急了
Lucia: Is it running low?
Jake: 每人500吧
Jake: 500 per person.
Tasha: 什么东西每人500
Tasha: What's 500 per person?
Jake: 每人500的那个房间对吧
Jake: 500 per person for that room, right?
Jake: 总体我们我们还花什么钱吗
Jake: Overall, are we spending money on anything else?
Lucia: 哈哈哈确实确实
Lucia: Haha, indeed, indeed.
Jake: 这个没办法
Jake: There's no way around this.
Jake: 对这个
Jake: Yes, this.
Tasha: 我看附近租的好多都是哈利波特的啊
Tasha: I see a lot of Harry Potter rentals nearby.
Alice: 因为这有那啥对哦
Alice: Because there's that, right.
Jake: 就这些都是奢侈品项目里边的奢侈品
Jake: These are all luxury items from the luxury project.
Jake: 这些都是
Jake: All of these are.
Katrina:  嗯北京特别大
Katrina: Hmm, Beijing is really big.
Lucia: 牛仔裤或者假的
Lucia: Jeans or fake ones.
Lucia: 当然现在关键是大家好像没有
Lucia: But the main thing now is that it seems like no one has...
Lucia: 就是就是我们自己的衣服凑
Lucia: ...enough of our own clothes to...
Lucia: 凑不出来
Lucia: ...make it work.
Lucia: 风格统一的一套否则的话也就
Lucia: To put together a matching set, otherwise...
Lucia: 是用自己的衣服也行
Lucia: ...we could just use our own clothes.
Lucia: 像我们之前上课的时候
Lucia: Like when we had classes before...
Lucia: 就最后汇报表演
Lucia: ...for the final performance...
Lucia: 就是我们老师就是挑的那种
Lucia: ...our teacher would choose...
Lucia: 就是大概三四十块钱的那种小上衣
Lucia: ...tops that were around 30 to 40 yuan.
Lucia: 然后底下一个五六十的那种裤子
Lucia: And pants that were about 50 to 60 yuan.
Lucia: 只不过他可能没有打过风格
Lucia: They might not have the same style...
Lucia: 就那种偏稍微休闲一点的风格
Lucia: ...but they had a more casual look.
Tasha: 永乐店
Tasha: Yongle Store.
Tasha: 不知道呀搜一搜
Tasha: Not sure, let's look it up.
Jake: 高德在国内是很常用吗
Jake: Is Gaode commonly used in China?
Jake: 嗯就是比百度地图要好
Jake: Yeah, it's better than Baidu Maps.
Jake: 通州还要再开
Jake: We still need to go to Tongzhou.
Jake: 18公里
Jake: 18 kilometers.
Shure: 走外卖到了
Shure: The delivery is here.
Jake: 走吃饺子吧
Jake: Let's go eat dumplings.
Jake: 走吧吃饺子
Jake: Yeah, let's go eat dumplings.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Alice: 需要拼不对
Alice: We need soy sauce, right?
Alice: 需要醋那个
Alice: We need vinegar too.
Jake: 那哎
Jake: Oh, yeah.
Jake: 要醋要带
Jake: We need to bring vinegar.
Jake: 带上去带上去
Jake: Take it upstairs.
Alice: 哦那什么时候录
Alice: So when are we recording?
Alice: 哎不对导数据呢
Alice: Oh, what about the data import?
Jake: 吃完OK哎呀
Jake: We'll do it after we eat, okay?
Shure: 去上个厕
Shure: I'm going to the bathroom.
Jake: 吃饺子
Jake: Let's eat dumplings.
Jake: 哈哈哈好主意
Jake: Haha, good idea.
Jake: 我们包个饺子吧
Jake: Let's make some dumplings.
Alice: 哈哈哈真的吗
Alice: Hahaha, really?
Jake: 不不不这个太麻烦了
Jake: No, no, no, this is too complicated.
Jake: 我们没有什么精力包饺子
Jake: We don't really have the energy to make dumplings.
Jake: 对时间还挺紧的
Jake: Yeah, time is pretty tight.
Katrina:  还要装饰房间
Katrina: We still have to decorate the room.
Katrina:  还要排舞啊
Katrina: And we need to practice the dance.
Katrina:  其实还蛮多
Katrina: There's actually a lot to do.
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 有人一起上楼吗
Alice: Is anyone going upstairs with me?
Jake: 嚯这这一身哈利波特吗
Jake: Whoa, is that a Harry Potter outfit?
Alice: 真的吗已经换装了
Alice: Really? I've already changed.
Alice: 嗯来了一个
Alice: Yep, one came.
Jake: 我刚刚远远一看
Jake: I just saw from a distance.
Jake: 我觉得这服装到底啥意思啊
Jake: I was wondering what the costume meant.
Jake: 这个啊
Jake: This one?
Jake: 刚刚他是
Jake: Just now, he was...
Jake: 就是过来的时候他的那个粉色是
Jake: When he came over, the pink part was...
Jake: 大概到一半就是黑的
Jake: About halfway down was black.
Jake: 粉的就是就你这个服装很好看
Jake: The pink part... Your costume looks really good.
Jake: 走吃饭去
Jake: Let's go eat.
Jake: 吃饺子去
Jake: Let's eat dumplings.
Alice: 你最爱的醋
Alice: Your favorite vinegar.
Alice: 上楼吧
Alice: Let's go upstairs.
Jake: 你们上楼收拾收拾
Jake: You guys go upstairs and tidy up.
Jake: 然后把这边
Jake: And then this side...
Jake: 空下来我就
Jake: Clear it out and I...
Jake: 哦是什么
Jake: Oh, what is it...
Jake: 我我我就测一个内餐
Jake: I'll prepare the inside meal.
Jake: 我测个外餐
Jake: I'll prepare the outside meal.
Jake: 来帮个忙吧
Jake: Come, give me a hand.
Jake: 我我在这转一圈大概要花两分钟哎
Jake: If I turn around here, it takes about two minutes.
Jake: 你你直接开场记来
Jake: You just start recording directly.
Shure: 哦对
Shure: Oh, right.
Jake: 然后大概就说一个十三点零五分
Jake: Then say around 13:05...
Jake: 我开始测外餐
Jake: I'll start preparing the outside meal.
Jake: 呃你在我房间待着
Jake: Uh, you stay in my room.
Jake: 然后我转两分钟
Jake: And then I turn around for two minutes.
Jake: 之后我们把这个
Jake: After that, we'll...
Jake: 就标定一个
Jake: We'll mark a...
Jake: 标定就
Jake: Mark it...
Shure: 今天是c对错
Shure: Today is C, right?
Jake: 对four
Jake: Yes, four.
Jake: 不第四天了我们
Jake: No, it's the fourth day for us.
Jake: 外面会有吗
Jake: Will it be outside?
路西：我很快就能把它搞好给他搬上楼去
Lucia: I can quickly finish it and move it upstairs.
路西：您放心吧
Lucia: Don't worry.
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's okay.
路西：我已经改造了这个精髓
Lucia: I've already modified the core part.
Jake: 然后一会我们把这个都关机
Jake: Then we'll turn everything off in a bit.
Jake: 呃关完机把充电宝插到那边
Jake: Uh, after turning everything off, plug the power bank over there.
Jake: 他还是有用
Jake: It still works.
Jake: 有一个是有用的
Jake: One of them still works.
Shure: 充电宝
Shure: The power bank.
Jake: 忙啥呢这两天
Jake: What have you been busy with these days?
Shure: 呦您来了哎
Shure: Oh, you're here!
Jake: 哦您一直在这啊
Jake: Oh, you've been here all along?
Shure: 喜欢您来
Shure: Glad you came.
Jake:那个帮我看一下哎
Jake: Hey, can you help me check this?
Jake: 哎不是问问修硕吗
Jake: Hey, aren't you asking Shure?
Jake: 那什么玩意那个
Jake: What is that thing?
Jake: 呃冰箱贴
Jake: Uh, a fridge magnet.
Shure: 冰箱贴什么
Shure: What about the fridge magnet?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：我是真看不出来是什么
Others: I really can't tell what it is.
Shure: 吃饺子
Shure: Eating dumplings.
Shure: 吃什么腊八蒜柿子
Shure: What are you eating? Laba garlic and tomatoes?
Shure: 你刚才在哼什么
Shure: What were you humming just now?
Katrina:  哎我刚哼的这首歌叫什么来着
Katrina: Hey, what's the name of the song I was humming just now?
Shure: 你哼的啥
Shure: What were you humming?
Shure: 你再哼一遍
Shure: Hum it again.
Katrina:  忘了
Katrina: I forgot.
Katrina:  7秒钟的记忆
Katrina: A 7-second memory.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 我怎么我怎么没有这个印象呢
Shure: How come I don't have any impression of it?
其他人：玫瑰发型真好
Others: The rose hairstyle is so good.
Shure: 梅梅发新砖了
Shure: Mei Mei released a new album.
Shure: 已经不是梅粉了
Shure: No longer a Mei fan.
Shure: 你那你说你上一张专辑你你最爱听
Shure: So, from your last album, which song did you like the most?
其他人：我上一张一首没听
Others: I didn't listen to a single song from the last album.
Shure: 嘿嘿什么东西
Shure: Hehe, what is that?
Shure: 你看这又当又立这种
Shure: Look at this, pretending to be something you're not.
Katrina:  倒点醋
Katrina: Pour some vinegar.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Shure: 你演唱会你不是把票卖了吗
Shure: Didn't you sell the tickets for your concert?
其他人：没卖啊
Others: No, we didn't sell them.
Katrina:  这是啥
Katrina: What's this?
Shure: 啊啊嗨
Shure: Ah, ah, hi.
Shure: 摸到梅梅大腿了吗
Shure: Did you touch Mei Mei's thigh?
其他人：梅梅离我就10米
Others: Mei Mei was just 10 meters away from me.
其他人：你要是在中国我肯定冲上去摸
Others: If we were in China, I would definitely rush up to touch her.
其他人：新加坡不太敢
Others: But in Singapore, I don't dare.
Shure: 法律比较严格是吗
Shure: Because the law is stricter, right?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina:  这是韭菜饼是吧
Katrina: This is chive pancake, right?
Jake: 是吧摸什么
Jake: Yeah, what are you touching?
Katrina:  那票多少钱
Katrina: How much were the tickets?
Katrina:  前排
Katrina: Front row.
Shure: 哎呀成功
Shure: Oh, success!
Shure: 虽然味可能不太一样
Shure: Although the taste might be a bit different.
Shure: 但是差不多差不多
Shure: But it's almost the same.
Jake: 那就更要问了
Jake: Then you should ask more.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 嗯呐这当多好吃的
Shure: Hmm, this is quite delicious.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 嗯呐
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 反正吃完
Shure: Anyway, after eating.
Shure: 12点了都
Shure: It's already 12 o'clock.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 还行不是还有其他的
Shure: It's okay, there are still other things.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 这碳引的这费劲
Shure: It's really tough to light this charcoal.
Shure: 这整的大块碳一点不好找
Shure: These big pieces of charcoal are hard to find.
Shure: 然后还埋少了呢碳
Shure: And I buried too little charcoal.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 忘了都忘了
Shure: Forgot, totally forgot.
Shure: 谁到了
Shure: Who arrived?
Shure: 嗯还得吃妈妈蒸现成的
Shure: Hmm, still have to eat mom's freshly steamed ones.
Shure: 嗯五一回去吃
Shure: Hmm, go back for May Day and eat.
Shure: 哈哈哈你别投
Shure: Hahaha, don't throw.
Shure: 洗吧你你整的我这
Shure: Go wash up, you're making a mess here.
Shure: 哎呀从现在
Shure: Oh man, from now on...
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure: 暗器
Shure: Hidden weapon
Shure: 出门
Shure: Going out
Shure: 你拉拉倒吧拉倒吧拉倒吧
Shure: Just drop it, drop it, drop it
Shure: 呵呵你还整
Shure: Haha, you still doing it
Shure: 你整的跟跟跟哎呀
Shure: You're doing it like, like, like, oh man
Shure: 行完完完再说
Shure: Alright, alright, let's talk later
Shure: 不着急不着急
Shure: No rush, no rush
Shure: 嗯呐看看吧
Shure: Yeah, let's see
Shure: 我就到时候跟人商量商量
Shure: I'll discuss it with people later
Shure: 嗯呐
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Shure: 哈哈你个便宜
Shure: Haha, you're so cheap
Shure: 哎呀妈你你
Shure: Oh my, you, you
Shure: 哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahaha, oh man
Shure: 愁死了可
Shure: It's driving me crazy
Shure: 愁死了
Shure: Driving me crazy
Jake: 开吃
Jake: Let's eat
Jake: 缺人是吧
Jake: Missing people, right?
Shure: 这家伙给整
Shure: This guy is making everyone tense
Shure: 整了一堆人紧张这家伙
Shure: Making everyone tense, this guy
Jake: 好哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, hahaha
Shure: 行行行
Shure: Alright, alright, alright
Jake: 我们也可以让碗活起来
Jake: We can also bring the bowls to life
Shure: 行完完完再说
Shure: Alright, alright, let's talk later
Jake: 全是青草全是草
Jake: It's all grass, all grass
Jake: 一桌子草
Jake: A table full of grass
Jake: 哈哈知道为什么吗
Jake: Haha, do you know why?
Jake: 就今天是一个节气
Jake: Because today is a special occasion
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahahaha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahaha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Shure: 行行行哎完完再说吧
Shure: Alright, alright, let's talk later
Shure: 完再说我这两天忙完呢
Shure: Let's talk later, I'm busy these days
Shure: 我24号之
Shure: On the 24th...
Shure: 后就没事了
Shure: Then it's all good.
Shure: 忙完再说吧
Shure: Let's talk after we're done.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 完完再说完再说
Shure: Finish it first, then we'll talk.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mmm.
Shure: 那票都买了反正
Shure: Anyway, the tickets are all bought.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 嗯行
Shure: Yeah, okay.
Shure: 好好好拜拜拜拜
Shure: Alright, alright, bye bye.
Shure: hello
Shure: Hello.
Jake: 可可行吗
Jake: Coco, is it okay?
Lucia: 可行应该是可行
Lucia: It should be fine.
Katrina:  可以啊
Katrina: Yes, it is.
Katrina:  但是哈利波特衣服一天都只要50块
Katrina: But Harry Potter costumes only cost 50 bucks a day.
Lucia: 但是我最好是能
Lucia: But I prefer if we could...
Lucia: 我们能在附近找到一个实体店租哦
Lucia: ...find a physical store nearby to rent from.
Lucia: 因为寄过来的话有一个稍微有点慢
Lucia: Because if it's shipped, it might be a bit slow.
Tasha: 但是那个的话还挺
Tasha: But that place is quite...
Jake: 没亮
Jake: Not bright.
Tasha: 对挺远的
Tasha: Yes, quite far.
Tasha: 然后25块钱一套
Tasha: And it's 25 bucks per set.
Tasha: 那一家他居然连鞋子都配
Tasha: That place even includes shoes.
Tasha: 配饰也都配
Tasha: And accessories too.
Shure: 配饰也都配
Shure: They include accessories too.
Katrina:  这么专业啊
Katrina: So professional!
Shure: 每次谢云中一来就
Shure: Every time Xie Yunzhong comes...
Shure: 咱们就开始练团是吧
Shure: ...we start practicing, right?
Jake: 对哈哈哈
Jake: Yeah, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈我有筷子
Jake: Hahaha, I have chopsticks.
Shure: 好像
Shure: Seems like...
Jake: 给俩勺子可以
Jake: Can I have two spoons?
Shure: 别别别别
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 咱又不是没筷子
Shure: We have chopsticks.
Alice: 那个柜子里好多筷子
Alice: There are lots of chopsticks in the cabinet.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure: 给我倒一点
Shure: Pour me a little.
Shure: 谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Alice: 这是芹菜叶吗
Alice: Is this celery leaves?
Shure: 我不知道啊香椿
Shure: I don't know, it's Chinese toon.
Alice: 这个
Alice: This one.
Alice: 这不是香椿吧
Alice: This isn't Chinese toon, is it?
Alice: 我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Alice: 不像香椿
Alice: Doesn't look like Chinese toon.
Tasha: 我们都有这么多鸡蛋了
Tasha: We already have so many eggs.
Tasha: 还要买个打鸡蛋吗
Tasha: Do we still need an egg beater?
Lucia: 就是只要我在家就敢吃炒蛋哈哈
Lucia: As long as I'm home, I'll dare to eat scrambled eggs, haha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Lucia: 笑话好冷
Lucia: That joke was so lame.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 我有点难
Shure: I'm having a hard time.
Lucia: 不是真不是我要逼迫大家吃的
Lucia: I'm really not forcing everyone to eat this.
其他人：这个炒鸡蛋好吃
Others: This scrambled egg is delicious.
Lucia: 嗯那就行
Lucia: Well, that's good then.
Lucia: 不是这些不是我点的
Lucia: These weren't ordered by me.
Lucia: 不要误会
Lucia: Don't misunderstand.
Lucia: 哎这啥情况
Lucia: Hey, what's going on?
Lucia: 又掉线了
Lucia: Disconnected again.
Jake: 又掉线了
Jake: Disconnected again.
Jake: 对好吧
Jake: Okay, fine.
Jake: 那就再连上吧
Jake: Let's reconnect.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Sigh.
Lucia: 但他应该有电
Lucia: But it should have power.
Lucia: 那为啥
Lucia: So why...
Alice: 杨老板这个是芹菜叶吗
Alice: Jake, is this celery leaves?
Jake: 呃我看一下菜单
Jake: Uh, let me check the menu.
Lucia: 新鲜
Lucia: Fresh.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 今天是试做
Lucia: Today is a trial run.
Jake: 呃这应该就是香椿苗炒鸡蛋
Jake: Uh, this should be Chinese toon sprouts with scrambled eggs.
Alice: 这个是香椿苗
Alice: This is Chinese toon sprouts?
Jake: 那就是叫它叫老味道蒸菜
Jake: Then it's called 'Old Taste Steamed Dish.'
Jake: 我不知道是什么
Jake: I don't know what it is.
Jake: 我看一下啊
Jake: Let me see.
Jake: 蒿子杆
Jake: Mugwort stems.
Lucia: 我想夹一个那个蛋
Lucia: I want to grab one of those eggs.
Shure: 锅贴吧
Shure: Potstickers, right?
Lucia: 这他是锅贴吗
Lucia: Are these potstickers?
Shure: 差不多吧
Shure: Pretty much.
其他人：没吃过我一直以为这种东西叫锅贴
Others: I've never eaten these. I always thought these were called potstickers.
Alice: 哦下面还有层嗯
Alice: Oh, there's another layer underneath, hmm.
其他人：嗯我草
Others: Hmm, what the heck
其他人：上面还有一层
Others: There's another layer on top
Lucia: 哦这种东西叫锅贴
Lucia: Oh, this thing is called "potstickers"
Lucia: 那这个是什么
Lucia: So what is this?
Lucia: 尝一下
Lucia: Let's give it a taste
其他人：像什么什么香河肉饼那种啊
Others: It's like those Xianghe meat pies, right?
Alice: 为什么没有人吃腊八蒜
Alice: Why isn't anyone eating Laba garlic?
Shure: 我吃糖蒜
Shure: I eat sweet garlic
Shure: 但不吃腊八蒜
Shure: But not Laba garlic
Alice: 为啥
Alice: Why not?
Shure: 因为就是它是坏掉的
Shure: Because it's, like, it's gone bad
其他人：这玩意不是糖蒜吗
Others: Isn't this sweet garlic?
Shure: 不是腊八蒜
Shure: No, it's not Laba garlic
Shure: 是腊八蒜嗯
Shure: This is Laba garlic, yeah
Alice: 糖蒜有皮
Alice: Sweet garlic has skin
Jake: 那是什么蒜
Jake: Then what garlic is this?
Alice: : 腊八蒜
Alice: It's Laba garlic
Jake: 腊八蒜
Jake: Laba garlic
Shure: 腊八蒜他这个是就是熟的蒜
Shure: Laba garlic, this one is cooked garlic
Shure: 那个糖弄糖蒜的时候是那种新鲜的蒜
Shure: When you make sweet garlic, it's with fresh garlic
Shure: 就是那种没没没烘过的那种蒜
Shure: The kind that hasn't been dried
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Lucia: 看起来像一个饼
Lucia: It looks like a pancake
Jake: 早餐10块
Jake: Breakfast for 10 bucks
Jake: 饼
Jake: Pancake
Jake: 撕了吧
Jake: Tear it up
Jake: 就在这撕了吧
Jake: Just tear it up here
Jake: 就在这撕掉
Jake: Tear it here
Jake: 看看怎么撕
Jake: Let's see how to tear it
Shure: 撕什么
Shure: Tear what?
Jake:撕饼
Jake: Tear the pancake
其他人：啊我吃一个哟
Others: Ah, I'm eating one, yo
其他人：13娘切菜籽
Others: 13th sister chops vegetables
Jake:哈哈哈挺好
Jake: Haha, it's pretty good
Lucia: 这也是香椿的吗
Lucia: Is this also Chinese toon?
Alice: 这个是茴香的啊
Alice: This one is fennel, huh
Jake: 撕完了哎
Jake: Finished tearing
Jake: 没撕完还有一个
Jake: Not finished, there's one more
Jake: 自行认领
Jake: Claim it yourself
Jake: 你说8个
Jake: You said 8
Katrina:  我今天早上吃多了面包
Katrina: I ate too much bread this morning.
Katrina:  今天早上那个
Katrina: This morning...
Katrina:  自己做面包
Katrina: Made the bread myself.
Katrina:  烤面包大厨的感觉
Katrina: Felt like a master baker.
Tasha: 不知道什么东西
Tasha: Don't know what that is.
Shure: 昨天没吃到
Shure: Didn't get to eat it yesterday.
Shure: 我的我的
Shure: My bad, my bad.
Shure: 我的肉
Shure: My meat.
Shure: 虽然不是我考的吧
Shure: Even though I didn't roast it.
Shure: 你应该感到很悲伤吧
Shure: You must feel really sad, huh?
Shure: 哎呀哎呀哎呀
Shure: Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Shure: 没有吃的哦
Shure: Nothing to eat.
其他人：昨天晚上太晚了
Others: It was too late last night.
Shure: 我们昨天晚上吃的都9点了
Shure: We ate at 9 last night.
Jake: 我们几点考完来着
Jake: What time did we finish roasting?
Jake: 9点半10点半
Jake: 9:30 or 10:30?
Alice: 10点半
Alice: 10:30.
Shure: 都12点多了
Shure: It was past 12 already.
Alice: 对就是
Alice: Exactly.
Jake: 肯定烤上
Jake: Definitely roasting.
Jake: 什么时候烤上呢
Jake: When did it start roasting?
Jake: 还不知道
Jake: Still don't know.
Katrina:  搞碳搞了半天
Katrina: Spent forever on the charcoal.
Katrina:  我看看拍照时间
Katrina: Let me check the photo time.
Alice: 每根头发丝都裹裹满了
Alice: Every strand of hair covered.
Alice: 那个烟的味道
Alice: With the smell of smoke.
Shure: 我昨天晚上还倒头就睡了
Shure: I just fell asleep right away last night.
Shure: 我靠昨天晚上就
Shure: I just...
Shure: 躺那躺一会
Shure: Lay there for a bit.
Shure: 然后就着了
Shure: And then fell asleep.
其他人：结果我那那一天跟刘海回去
Others: So that day, I went back with Liu Hai.
其他人：我准备两点钟躺一会
Others: Planned to lie down for a bit at 2.
其他人：躺到三点看个关
Others: Lie down until 3 to watch something.
其他人：然后躺到了啥
Others: Then what happened?
Jake: 谁赢了
Jake: Who won?
其他人：嗯打平啊
Others: Uh, it was a draw.
其他人：这个点球跑满了
Others: The penalty shootout was full.
其他人：还好我没看
Others: Glad I didn't watch.
Jake: 是吧你
Jake: Right?
Jake: 你是曼城球迷
Jake: You're a Man City fan.
Jake: 哈兰德
Jake: Haaland
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 曼彻斯特
Shure: Manchester
其他人：其实我是姆巴佩的球迷
Others: Actually, I'm an Mbappe fan.
其他人：所以我很期
Others: So I am very
其他人：所以我很期待姆巴佩打皇马
Others: So I am very excited about Mbappe playing against Real Madrid.
其他人：姆巴佩很快要去皇马
Others: Mbappe is soon going to Real Madrid.
Lucia: 他真的要去皇马了吗
Lucia: Is he really going to Real Madrid?
Jake: 打巴黎赢了吗
Jake: Did they beat Paris?
Jake: 就是要打皇马
Jake: They have to play Real Madrid.
其他人：马上还要打波特
Others: They still have to play Porto.
其他人：然后皇马打多特蒙德
Others: And then Real Madrid plays Dortmund.
其他人：哦不对哦
Others: Oh no, wait.
其他人：皇马打拜仁
Others: Real Madrid plays Bayern.
Jake: 我以前都不知道
Jake: I never knew before.
Jake: 达瓦尼自从我做这个和这个
Jake: Davani, since I did this and that.
Jake: 啊就这个是我们
Jake: Ah, this is our...
Jake: 我2022年的一篇paper
Jake: My 2022 paper.
Jake: 他态度比较
Jake: His attitude is quite...
Jake: 这个叫叫panelbig
Jake: This is called panelbig.
其他人：对确实这个当时一看就是大巴黎
Others: Yes, indeed, at that time, it looked like Paris Saint-Germain.
Jake: 对就是这个
Jake: Yes, exactly this.
Jake: 是80年代TSG
Jake: It’s the 80s TSG.
Jake: 就是大巴黎的那个logo
Jake: It's the PSG logo.
Jake: 嗯然后我们稍微改造改造
Jake: Mm, then we made some modifications.
Jake: 改成了我们这个分割的
Jake: Changed it into our segmented version.
Jake: 就它是一个情景分割
Jake: It's a scene segmentation.
Jake: 嗯一看是青年分支
Jake: Mm, you can tell it’s a youth branch.
Jake: 就就就割出来的这个东西
Jake: We just segmented this out.
Shure: 所以这个跟大巴黎是真的有关系是吗
Shure: So, does this have something to do with Paris Saint-Germain?
Jake: 简称是就是PSG啊
Jake: The abbreviation is PSG.
Jake: 就硬凑一个简称
Jake: Just made up an abbreviation.
Shure: 就是就是
Shure: So, so...
Shure: 正好这个简称是一样的是吗
Shure: The abbreviation just happens to be the same, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 就是先出了这个名字
Jake: We came up with the name first.
Jake: 然后简称PSG
Jake: Then the abbreviation PSG.
Jake: 然后我上网一搜
Jake: Then I searched online.
Jake: 我靠是个球队
Jake: I found out it was a team.
Jake: 哈哈我才知道
Jake: Haha, that's when I knew.
Lucia:巴黎圣日耳曼对
Lucia: Paris Saint-Germain
Shure: 大巴黎
Shure: PSG
Shure: 他不止有球队
Shure: They don't just have a football team
Shure: 还有那个电竞的队伍
Shure: They also have an esports team
Shure: 吃困了
Shure: I'm sleepy after eating
Shure: 吃完就想睡
Shure: Want to sleep after eating
Shure: 睡醒了就饿
Shure: Hungry after sleeping
Shure: 饿完就想吃
Shure: Want to eat after being hungry
Shure: 感觉感觉人生已经
Shure: Feels like life is just
Jake: 对这才是生活
Jake: Yeah, that's life
Jake: 一个life就应该这个样子
Jake: That's how life should be
Shure: 确实
Shure: Totally
Jake: 跟里面夹了很多戏
Jake: Adding lots of drama
Jake: 太那个了
Jake: It's just too much
Shure: 不真实我们
Shure: Unreal, we
Shure: 明天搞啊
Shure: Let's do it tomorrow
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 像只蛆一样的蠕动
Shure: Wriggling like a maggot
巴黎圣日耳曼对我在床上躺一天
Paris Saint-Germain, I'm lying in bed all day
陌生人：对你应该给我300
Stranger: Yeah, you should give me 300
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
陌生人：对呵呵可以不
Stranger: Yeah, can you?
Shure: 我靠我让你看
Shure: Damn, I let you watch
Shure: 我在床上躺着
Shure: I'm lying in bed
陌生人：对你都是看天花板
Stranger: Yeah, you just stare at the ceiling
陌生人：我又看不到你躺着
Stranger: I can't see you lying there
Shure: 可以不那我把眼镜放这块
Shure: Can I just put my glasses here
陌生人：可以不
Stranger: Can I?
Shure: 然后让他拍
Shure: And let him film it
Shure: 我躺着
Shure: Me lying there
Shure: 就是让他以为人类是一个草履虫
Shure: So he thinks humans are like paramecia
Jake: 那为什么会眼镜
Jake: Then why the glasses?
Shure: 只能进行简单的生命活动
Shure: Only capable of simple life activities
Lucia: 哈哈哈救命啊
Lucia: Hahaha, help me!
Shure: 感觉吃的差不多了
Shure: I feel like I've eaten enough
Shure: 我好饿
Shure: I'm so hungry
Shure: 呸我好好饱
Shure: Oops, I'm so full
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake: 谢斌竹什么时候答辩
Jake: When is Xie Binzhu's defense?
Jake: 模拟答辩
Jake: Mock defense
陌生人：我们导师太懒了
Stranger: Our advisor is too lazy
陌生人：不搞
Stranger: Doesn't do it
Shure: 然后分怎么算
Shure: So how are the grades calculated?
陌生人：分他想怎么打怎么打
Stranger: He grades however he wants
Jake: 就学院要求
Jake: It's a requirement by the department
Jake: 但是导师不管
Jake: But the advisor doesn't care
陌生人：但是按道理
Stranger: But logically
陌生人：我的老师应该会给我打最高分啊
Stranger: My advisor should give me the highest score
Jake: 为什么
Jake: Why?
陌生人：因为他前几次从来没看过都是最高分
Stranger: Because he never looked at it the previous times and always gave the highest score
Lucia: 哇这样的导师哪里找
Lucia: Wow, where can I find such an advisor?
Shure: 然后之前
Shure: And then before
陌生人：我还问了一下
Stranger: I even asked about it
陌生人：就我的导师是我老板他
Stranger: My advisor is actually my boss
陌生人：他带张子成
Stranger: He's mentoring Zhang Zicheng
陌生人：然后他没名额了
Stranger: But he ran out of slots
陌生人：挂了一个导师
Stranger: So he assigned me to another advisor
陌生人：：然后还问了个老板
Stranger: Then I asked another boss
陌生人：我说我要不要去加一下他微信啊
Stranger: I asked if I should add him on WeChat
陌生人：要不要搞
Stranger: Should I do it?
陌生人：他说能不烦他尽量别烦他
Stranger: He said if you can avoid bothering him, don't bother him
Shure: 哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahaha, hey
Jake: 反他就扣分
Jake: If you bother him, he'll deduct points
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈你只要跟我说一句话
Shure: Hahaha, if you just say one word to me
Shure: 我就给你扣一分
Shure: I'll deduct one point
陌生人：所以我到现在
Stranger: So up till now
陌生人：我到现在没跟他讲过一句话
Stranger: I haven't said a single word to him
Jake: 准备满分准备满分
Jake: Prepare for a perfect score
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm
Jake: 准备满分
Jake: Prepare for a perfect score
陌生人：咱只说过一次
Stranger: We only talked once
陌生人：最开始给他发的邮件
Stranger: The first email I sent him
陌生人：他回我一切信息
Stranger: He replied with all the info
陌生人：请不要联系我
Stranger: And told me not to contact him
陌生人：联系男老师就行
Stranger: Just contact the male advisor
Shure: 男老师是什么东西
Shure: What is a male advisor?
陌生人：就是张晨啊
Stranger: It's Zhang Chen
陌生人：嗯最近的地点是
Stranger: Hmm, the nearest location is
陌生人：20号叫中文名称
Stranger: The 20th is called the Chinese name.
陌生人：嗯然后就24号叫PPT
Stranger: Mm, then the 24th is called the PPT.
Shure: 嗯 24号叫final report
Shure: Mm, the 24th is called the final report.
Shure: PPT呢 30号
Shure: PPT is on the 30th.
陌生人：PPT 30号
Stranger: PPT is on the 30th.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm.
陌生人：中间没有了
Stranger: Nothing in between.
陌生人：二十一二张没了
Stranger: The 21st and 22nd are gone.
陌生人：没有 24号
Stranger: There's nothing on the 24th.
Shure: 就是所有周边材料加上那个
Shure: Just all the surrounding materials plus that.
Shure: 那什么都要交
Shure: Everything has to be submitted.
陌生人：之前老记着RE
Stranger: I used to always remember RE.
陌生人：原来那个是刘钗的弟弟啊
Stranger: So that was Liu Chai's younger brother, huh?
Shure: 你是他什么的弟弟啊
Shure: What are you to him, his younger brother?
陌生人：他们班他们才抓住啊
Stranger: Their class, they just caught him.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 你抓住他写多少了
Shure: How much did you catch him writing?
陌生人：我抓住就写了19页
Stranger: I caught him and he wrote 19 pages.
Shure: 好
Shure: Good.
陌生人：在变点数据交了个final再上去
Stranger: Changed some data, submitted a final, then went up.
Jake: 我当年毕设什么初期报告忘交了
Jake: Back in the day, I forgot to submit my initial report for my graduation project.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Jake: 对对恶劣伪报扣了10%
Jake: Yeah, for false reporting, I got 10% deducted.
Jake: 最后90
Jake: Ended up with 90.
Shure: 最后九十
Shure: Ended up with 90.
陌生人：是因为你导师很好
Stranger: It's because your advisor is really good.
Shure: 是因为人家做的很牛逼
Shure: It's because what you did was really impressive.
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Shure: 你这你就是
Shure: You're just...
Shure: 你这孩子就不会说话
Shure: You just don't know how to talk.
Shure: 领导都把话递到这了
Shure: The leader already put it this way.
Shure: 哈哈哎呦我的妈呀
Shure: Haha, oh my gosh.
Shure: 哎呦这是为什么
Shure: Oh gosh, why is this?
Shure: 你们导师好啊
Shure: Your advisor is really good.
Jake: 导师确实
Jake: The advisor truly is.
陌生人：只有只有好的导师才会召最强的人
Stranger: Only good advisors recruit the strongest people.
陌生人：你知道吗
Stranger: You know that?
陌生人：唉一般好的都一抢而空
Stranger: Sigh, generally good ones are always in high demand.
陌生人：只有能力强能抢到这种名额
Stranger: Only those with strong abilities can grab such spots.
Shure: 别找补了
Shure: Stop making excuses.
Shure: 明年科员都不一定是了
Shure: Next year, you might not even be a clerk.
Shure: 你快去山东进修2年呗
Shure: You should go to Shandong for further studies for 2 years.
Alice: 哈哈山东
Alice: Haha, Shandong.
Shure: 山东
Shure: Shandong.
陌生人：90分有点夸张
Stranger: 90 points is a bit exaggerated.
Shure: 我一多一分我都不要
Shure: I wouldn't take even one point more.
Shure: 他只要给我60就行
Shure: Just give me 60, that's enough.
Tasha: 为什么要考90分
Tasha: Why aim for 90 points?
Lucia: 他考了90分
Lucia: He scored 90 points.
Tasha: 他考了90分
Tasha: He scored 90 points.
Lucia: 嗯哦
Lucia: Yep.
Tasha: 我还以为啊
Tasha: I thought...
Shure: 我说我要60分就行
Shure: I said 60 points is fine for me.
Shure: 多一分都是多给我的
Shure: Anything more is just extra.
Shure: 都没有用
Shure: It's useless.
陌生人：你企战是60吗
Stranger: Is your company strategy 60 points?
Shure: 啊企战
Shure: Ah, company strategy.
Shure: 企战是什么
Shure: What is company strategy?
Jake: 企业战略我都记得啊
Jake: I remember the company strategy.
Shure: 不是应该不是60
Shure: No, it shouldn't be 60.
陌生人： 我真的是
Stranger: Seriously...
陌生人：我跟你们说
Stranger: Let me tell you guys,
陌生人：我觉得我考试非常想提前交卷了
Stranger: I felt like handing in my test early.
Shure: 然后呢
Shure: And then?
陌生人：那个考试在考试前我实在是真的不会
Stranger: Before the test, I really didn't know anything.
陌生人：然后我本来是有时间复习
Stranger: I had time to review,
陌生人：但那段时间繁华太好差了
Stranger: but I got too distracted.
陌生人：然后在看繁华
Stranger: Got too distracted.
陌生人：所以那个真的没复习
Stranger: So I didn't review at all.
Shure: 我带他看的
Shure: I distracted him.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
陌生人：然后考试的时候我三三十多分钟交卷
Stranger: During the test, I handed it in after thirty minutes.
陌生人：因为我一堂课没跟你差不多
Stranger: I was just like you, didn't attend classes.
陌生人：因为我一堂课没有去过
Stranger: I never attended a single class.
陌生人：所以我不知道老师长什么样
Stranger: So I didn't even know what the teacher looked like.
陌生人：其实那个监考老师就是我们的老师
Stranger: Turns out the invigilator was our teacher.
陌生人：但是我不知道
Stranger: But I didn't know.
陌生人：我以为他只是一个小小学生
Stranger: I thought he was just a little student.
陌生人：我就直接小学小学生我就直接
Stranger: I just thought, a little student...
Lucia: 小学生小学生真是
Lucia: A little student, really.
陌生人：我就直接叫了
Stranger: I just called directly.
陌生人：叫了之后还是他跟我说的
Stranger: After I called, he still told me.
Shure: 老师在这阴阳怪气的拿他卷跟你讲啊
Shure: The teacher was sarcastically talking to you with his paper.
Shure: 就这种这么早交卷的
Shure: The kind who submits the paper so early.
Shure: 一字不写的
Shure: Without writing a single word.
Shure: 不是不是不是没写几个字的
Shure: No, no, no, just wrote a few words.
Shure: 这种肯肯定过不了
Shure: This kind definitely won't pass.
Shure: 就肯必须挂他哈哈哈
Shure: They must fail him, haha.
Lucia: 那最后没挂呀
Lucia: But in the end, he didn't fail.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
陌生人：只能说老师人太好了
Stranger: You could say the teacher was just too nice.
陌生人：可能看我写的屁话太多了
Stranger: Maybe he saw I wrote too much nonsense.
Shure: 不不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 然后他他他说完这番话我就添两个字
Shure: Then after he said that, I added two words.
Shure: 我就啪就交了就走了
Shure: Then bam, I sent the message.
陌生人：然后他又回来把这个把这个噩耗传给
Stranger: Then he came back and delivered the bad news.
Shure: 对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 我就想想赶紧告诉他这个好消息
Shure: I just wanted to quickly tell him the good news.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
陌生人：我我我们寒假都没过好
Stranger: Our winter break was ruined.
Shure: 我感觉我们两个
Shure: I feel like both of us...
Jake: 学了一个
Jake: Learned one...
Jake:寒假企业战略
Jake: Winter break business strategy.
陌生人：没有学还是不会学
Stranger: No matter how much we learned, it was useless.
Lucia: 学是学不了一假期了
Lucia: Couldn't learn it all in one break.
Shure: 他妈的
Shure: Damn it.
Shure: 我还有一门课
Shure: I had another class.
Shure: 因为平时有一次测测验没去
Shure: I missed a quiz once.
Shure: 就是平时小测
Shure: Just a small quiz.
Shure: 然后我因为那天那个实习有有事
Shure: I had something to do with my internship that day.
Shure: 然后我就问那老师
Shure: So I asked the teacher.
Shure: 我说平时分咱那个没过
Shure: I said my regular score didn't pass.
Shure: 但是我总成绩过了
Shure: But my total score passed.
Shure: 能不能给我过
Shure: Can you pass me?
Shure: 他说可以的
Shure: He said yes.
Shure: 然后结果最后给我挂了
Shure: But in the end, he failed me.
Shure: 然后让我重新补了一遍
Shure: Then made me retake it.
Shure: 平时小测
Shure: The small quiz.
Shure: 唉就特别的耻辱
Shure: It was so humiliating.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Shure: 有两门吧
Shure: There are two courses, right?
Shure: 我记得我有一门平时无所谓
Shure: I remember one of my courses doesn't matter much.
Shure: 有一门平时不行
Shure: One course is not doing well.
Shure: 唉我不知道
Shure: Sigh, I don't know.
Shure: 反正他不是他自己亲口说的
Shure: Anyway, he didn't say it himself.
Shure: 然后最后搞这种
Shure: Then, in the end, it turned out like this.
Jake: 走吧换眼镜
Jake: Let's go change glasses.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: disconnect finish
Shure: Disconnect finish.
Shure: 完了我这又没有那个finish那个键
Shure: Oh no, I don't have the finish button here.
Alice: 我也是哦
Alice: Me neither.
Alice: 好了
Alice: Got it.
Shure: connecting
Shure: Connecting.
Shure: oh okay
Shure: Oh, okay.